all right uh the bills have decided to
unretire a number that was not actually
retired the o.j simpson number
unofficially set aside and it had been
set aside for 40 years this was a story
last week because sonora's perry wanted
to wear number 32 the bills decided to
reissue number 32 and that's fine o.j
simpson didn't have a problem with it
but andre reed hall of fame receiver
whose number is in that similar limbo
where it's not officially retired but
it's unofficially set aside he's got a
problem with the number being issued
because of what oj simpson did in his
careers has nothing to do with anything
that happened off the field some people
would say the numbers shouldn't be worn
by anyone with the bills because of of
o.j simpson's legal issues and you know
the not the least of which and the worst
of which the accusations of double
murder and he ultimately was found
responsible in civil court for those two
deaths the idea that he did what he did
on the field and that should be
respected and nobody dared to wear that
number when i played andre reid said if
there was a 32 they turned it into a 23
there could never be another oj i look i
it's an interesting one
i feel like at some level andre reed is
worried he's going to be next i really i
hate to boil it down to people worrying
about their self-interest but so much of
of those views
are driven ultimately by how it affects
me and if o.j simpson's number is no
longer in that unofficial category of
not being used the next thing you know
there's going to be a num another number
83 running around for the buffalo bills
when andre reid's number not retired but
set into that same status that o.j
simpson's number had had uh occupied
yeah but i mean slight little off-field
difference in their life so i don't
think andre reed has to worry about it i
don't think this is something that you
know so to me that's an interesting
conversation it really is i mean
what do you do in this case i know oj
simpson deserved to have his number
retired and 32 not to be used by the
things he did on the field but damn he
kind of wiped that away with what he did
off the field after he left that do you
continue to pay that respect to him and
not give the number even though
oh he allegedly murdered two people
which like allegedly an air quotation
marks you know i don't know we kind of
know he did it like you said in the
civil case and it just i don't know so
what do you do in that case do you
continue to honor that number even
though the guy is seen as a murderer by
most people in our country
well i i think there's an argument to be
made for not using it because of the
off-field incidents i that too i know
you could do it you're not setting it
aside to honor him you're setting it
aside so there's never another buffalo
bill running around in number 32 making
people think of o.j simpson i'm just not
a fan of retiring numbers forever i to
me it's like it's like space for garbage
eventually you're gonna run out right
eventually there's gonna be nowhere
however many years it takes there will
eventually be a time where there's no
more room for our garbage and there's
only a hundred numbers that you can
choose from eventually if teams retire
these numbers forever they're going to
run out so i if it's i don't think
numbers should be retired i i could see
like you set it aside for 50 years but
at some point it goes back into
circulation and i think for o.j simpson
40 years is long enough and for andre
reed at some point 30 years 40 years is
going to be enough you put the number
back in circulation because eventually
you're going to run out of numbers yeah
yeah i guess so i i i don't know if i
totally i mean yeah eventually you are
but i mean that could be a thousand
years from now i don't know when it is i
mean yeah you're right eventually
but the new york yankees haven't run out
of any numbers yet and nobody's retiring
more damn numbers than they have so uh i
don't know that's not my main concern
yet but i do think your point about o.j
simpson whether yeah are you honoring
him are you dishonoring him what are you
doing with that jersey i mean i really i
don't know what to say here i have no
definitive answer either way i mean
really in my heart i feel like no he
does not deserve to be honored anymore
uh and the 32 should be allowed to be
worn because of something he did off the
field and he hasn't act acted
appropriate to to have the jersey
retired but then i i hear what you're
saying too it's also like damn who would
really want to wear it and be associated
with that number and that guy to go
along with it so uh truly an interesting
kind of conversation
and by the way there's only 25 players
on a baseball team so you can retire 75
and still be good to go right for
football you got 53. so the the you've
got you've got a little more smaller
margin per error right right and and
then
look uh you know 100 years from now
right
yeah are
are football fans going to be thinking
about the guys who played now and these
numbers are going to be retired guys who
played 50 years ago 100 years from now
are they like
it's just it's it's not going to have
any relevance
it's at some point though
they're going to have to
un-retire numbers that have been
supposedly permanently retired if they
continue to retire these numbers or at
some point you just have to stop
retiring numbers altogether
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports